her whole life is turned upside down
they got two kids and all that stuff
how's their life upside down and just
got in a terrible car accident is he
dead no he narrowed that's sideways
that's not upside down okay so it sucks
for her it's sideways sucks
she started fearing that he got in this
car accident because you know it's your
fault for being all Shakespeare about it
if you hit me up my life's so upside
down you mean it just sucks that
qualifies as Shakespeare
okay can I say something now we know why
why hates JK news sometimes
you're making me upside down right now
doesn't even give him a chance and I
thought I interrupted a lot I just
joined Bart I was just praising your
literally little skills I wonder how
that's gonna type out yeah good luck
Ryan you put that in your captions dude
okay so uh she sideways sucked her life
away there you go